you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game okay what to do
how about okay a French why not
okay let's see
d5 it is uh-huh okay well let's try for
a winner are there should be four I've
seen captures I've seen push which is
most common night and g2e - hmm okay I
can recall out reviewing the white side
of this with uh with an engine that's so
long ago and that was one of the
suggestions but I believe black is able
to equalize I'm not sure exactly how but
let's see what to consider
well this is my better Bishop and
normally I'd be you know when I played
Bishop before I did that with the
intention to take one day and damage the
structure but it's a bit different now
white is aiming to maintain the
structure with this move so soon a
question will be asked of my bishop I
feel like I should just play Knight to
f6
and just pressurize e5e for some more
but I need to be prepared because II
five could be played and my night I'll
have to find a new home so maybe a
simpler way to do it you know if I'm
doing this I'm basically saying
you know I'm okay with giving white some
space advantage but maybe I'm not so
okay I think I'm going to capture
and on III on
give up my bishop instead I'm gonna drop
back so pretty modest deployment here I
could challenge the knight right away
and why not let's see how white reacts
this is a little bit awkward he will
need to move again unless white intends
to do something like this but it doesn't
seem right I believe a knight move is
called for here to reinforce e4 Knight
g3 it is
okay well at some point I'm gonna want
to challenge the d4 pawn with c5 so I
think I'm gonna want my night on d7
should I do that right now
um yeah why not let's hang on for a
second
yeah let's get this in right now just
connect Knights we could have many minor
pieces exchanged could very easily see
both Knights exchange my queen Knight
may revisit well not revisit but I might
step foot on f6 with my Queen night as
well my problem piece is my light square
bishop so I know I threw out there I
want this break-in but I can also maybe
consider some type of light square
Bishop move like this or maybe b6 Bishop
b7
okay well
what to do here I wonder what way white
is going to Castle you know
kingside queenside not quite sure this
is certainly a move directed at the c5
break
hmm well I think it's okay to commit my
king this pawn is something that maybe I
could bite at if white really wanted to
go Queen side who knows maybe a quick
beep on advance yeah I think I can
safely just castle so let's do this at
some point it may be interesting to
throw a punch at the dark square Bishop
he's a bit exposed on the third-ranked
accessible I can still insist on this
and I believe that this is the direction
I'm going to go in
I don't want to take here so soon
because if there's a worst piece for
white I would identify that as the night
on g3 he's out of this ideal zone for
the Knights
so I'd like to see night tags here and
then he is not really a great piece okay
I'm happy to see that this bishop is not
pointing at my King that might be a way
to show that the light square bishop oh
it might be a way to highlight the fact
that my light square Bishop isn't
contributing to this position just yet
why putting their light square bishop to
work however there must be some idea
connected with this and it may be aimed
at my idea to fianchetto
I wonder if I got b6 Bishop f3 in am
Bishop d7 I'm losing material
hmm
it's a bit annoying I go be six well
let's see I mean I could baby step it if
I really wanted to but ideally I would
like to get in c5 in one shot
what was my last move castles I'm
already thinking back was this a slight
in accuracy should I have tried to make
sure my bishop gets on this dog and all
sooner oh well we're gonna we're gonna
try to work with it
v6 hmm v6 Bishop to f3 I could just move
my rook out of the way yeah maybe I'm
just overthinking it you know we could
just get the rook out of the line of
fire and at the same time white also has
to be careful that their King does not
get stuck in the center as this is also
a possibility okay well let's get the
bishop there
probably just an equal ish position
it is the type however where I could see
black maybe become the side that maybe
plays for something there may soon be
some target on the queenside now that's
a bit surprising I'm most certainly
taking with the night my night cancels
out there's from the forward movements
also if we have a light square bishop
exchange I'm running with I'm playing
with the the better Bishop this may be a
target okay so an aggressive move here I
could play c5 hmm I want to make sure
these cut these are Queen side pawns
don't get too far advanced well at some
point I may have a a tempo against g2 I
think I must strike with c5
if the Queens are off at some point I
may be able to make a move like h5h for
that I couldn't convenience the night
that may factor in somehow so any other
candidate moves beside c5 I I don't
think so okay let's go with it
and to be honest I'm not
how to recapture I don't know if I want
to play this position with dark square
Bishop son or not in the end if if white
initiates this capture on c5 one way or
the other I could end up with split
pawns and I'm just going to have to be
content with that I will have a
half-open B file rook to b8 would seem
sensible if the Queen's are still around
I believe a post on b6 would be quite
good
I don't want to allow b4
to to be played too easily so here we go
hmm with the pawn or the bishop
well I am threatening to damage their
structure when I do this so yeah I think
is I think it's okay to take with the
[ __ ] up yeah let's get one more piece
exchanged mm-hmm let's see could have
many exchanges just we're soon to have a
an endgame here the Queen's off Bishop
takes Bishop takes pawn takes Queen
takes rook F takes o my king could start
to play what concerns me then in this in
in that end game is b4 mmm you know what
that's enough to convince me to maybe
take with the pawn here so that my
bishop
combats this b4 advance yeah I think
it's important I do it like this because
that b4 move would be tough to meet if I
would take then there's this they have
an a file and if I don't take then we
have b5 and he's in my territory and
that's not cool with me at all
they get started running the a and B
pawns and really really scary so I think
I made the correct decision here so
they're clearly lining up B form okay
well this is just running into pins it
allows before so I'm looking at just a
five uh yeah so let's go with it I got
some serious light-square weaknesses on
the queenside I would not like to have a
knight here or even a bishop fortunately
he is a long way off from doing anything
great on the Queen side at some point a
4 can be an idea on pond restricting to
if a 4 is in and this pawn is advancing
a 3 can be a target after a capture ok
avoiding the dark square Bishop exchange
so they're really trying to push through
its b4 but I may be okay if it's just
one pawn you know I could control the
one pawn if B force is in there
I look to block hate on c5
hmm I want more to consider well I could
play Queen to b6 there isn't this pin
anymore it still makes white work a
little bit harder to even get that
advance in I don't see why not I mean my
queen wants to play doesn't she I think
she knows her place right now so what do
we got here one two three four
on the B for square and White has one
two three so not enough this Knight is a
struggling piece still a struggling
piece my Bishop is very strong at some
point again this can factor in mate
threats or maybe even a bishop takes
within some fancy Queen move picking
something unprotected up so he's still
out of the ball game this is a
possibility at some point maybe they're
lining up this
hmm what truck to go to the D file can I
go can I go with this it feels a little
bit too early to do that like maybe be
before it's played and then there starts
to be some action along the V file all
right let's run with this first on
Bishop here I think it loses Queen here
and I think that this is definitely the
correct rook to go with because
something still may happen on the a file
b4 break my rook would like some play on
the a file so of the two rooks to go to
the d8 square it's definitely the right
one I'm almost certain it's the right
one
okay
what now that's a pretty strong Bishop
must be said oh you know what I think I
have an idea
one related to forming a battery with my
bishop being the leader let's try for
that and this also maybe prepares a for
where the bishop would serve well he
would be the better defender of a pawn
on a4 than the brook because soon with
the only one open file it's going to be
important that my rooks are in a
position to always recapture so this
move is preparing a for as well as maybe
Queen b7 the g2 point after all is
unprotected one attacker one defender
this is a sensitive point
so if I could induce f3 which may be
right around the corner that would be
nice a way to avoid this type of move
would be rook here and to meet Queen b7
with Bishop f1 we're gonna see about
that well first things first if I if I
do this maybe rook takes and then Bishop
takes here no I don't think so let's go
with this first and see how they react
Oh
also this Maysoon factor in if the
bishop drops back here this isn't
supported so much hmm at the same time
on h5 there's bishop takes and then
Knight takes
it's close to maybe happening I could
try for this knight takes Bishop takes
skewers
should I play a four or just Knight to
e4 we both need flight squares um I'm
gonna keep the tension I think yeah
let's let's go with this a form over I
don't like that my rook had to babysit a
five so there we go I like my position
it's uh it's a tense one just one one
little missed up and something bad can
happen
all right rook recapture right here I
guess mm-hmm okay
Wow are we gonna have like a bishop
ending Bishop ending only I have
anything better than jerk takes rook
here
how about I throw the Queen in the
corner
yeah I would like to get my Bishop on
this diagonal this is their best piece
definitely the best minor piece
worst piece this guy
if I'm to identify a worst piece for me
maybe the bishop my knight isn't a good
spot my bishop is one of my better
pieces still coordinated well with my
queen I would like to see this move
there may be some sacrifice on f3 here
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight here
there may be a timely check as soon as
that F pawn moves this diagonals opened
up their King is vulnerable if I go
forward with some type of flight square
right around this point I'd be leaning
towards h6 but honestly I'd like to get
more out of a move like that
h5 all right let's get to the open file
so are they gonna challenge yeah
Queen exchange I really don't want to
clean exchange let's keep the tension
let's keep pressure on g2 let's see if
they're if they become a bit impatient
and make a night move maybe then I could
immediately hop into e4 I think that's
what slow actually with the Queen on d3
now maybe this is right around the
corner because takes takes my bishop
would have some counter punch on b2 so
this is maybe something there is a
difference I'm noticing now with the
Queen on d3 when compared to c2
this might be the thing that really
makes the position breakdown some for
white right now can I go through with it
I'm gonna try for it this is this is now
the move on I spoke of this feels like
several several moves ago but I think it
now has its place
I shouldn't have so much concern about
the night having pressure on these
squares because my bishop would be
patrolling the long diagonal scooping up
this guy he would find a nice post here
why can't go pawn grabbing this bishop
is not playing the two pawns that are
split here I have covered with my
bishops
and one more I am under three minutes we
got 24 moves in all right well
do I give that night a kick right now ah
yeah let's do it I might be able to
break this down further h3 I want to
keep the Queens on in general I think
that's the the correct correct approach
this h-bond is the you may turn out to
be the m-v-p the most valuable pawn cell
h3 on takes this is getting broken down
big-time I have all these squares
covered very well entry point squares
I think h3 is the move
anything else to consider this is a
loose piece on e5 let's do it
okay so they have a super vulnerable
King
I have a g7f seven he's six structure
happy with I have a flight square who
knows this if it's the greatest it could
always be controlled still but
and still a little bit off takes a bit
more coordination
so here takes and then Bishop here I
don't have to take your just yet
huh
less than two should I just take you
right away huh now let me let me get
right back here it's just a many-many
improvement with my queen
some pressure on the V file I'd like to
see the bishop move then I take and then
the King is in the line of fire
all righty it's not the time to make
some dark square bishop exchange now as
soon as I move my knight they're going
to move their knight wonder if I was to
fast with h3
you know what I could make use of this
square but maybe I should take first
yeah let's split these guys up so now
Queen b3 kind of inching in some unit
pins the bishop let's do this
I don't know what our next move is but
this kind of feels right
active square
maybe this no no this is still a strong
piece the Queen can't go too far I am
putting pressure on c4
oh well I should maybe be looking a bit
more over here huh yeah let's do this
let's eye up these holes over here
there's yeah these are these are the
more important squares to be hung up
most likely the ones that are right near
the king because these guys are split
isolated pawns the squares in front of
them are all holes
so these two I'd like to have a dark
square Bishop exchange in a knight on
one of these two squares that'd be a
killer can I make that happen
hmm
well let's get this moving
to the open file maybe the back rank
can offer a queen exchange I really
don't want a queen exchange
well actually if they go with a queen
extend this Queen is restricted so there
they can't call it a queen exchange here
because I could exchange and then take
here oh oh what about her
this is pretty much a passing move I'm
not quite sure what to do I don't want
to budge just yet with my night I want
to do this but I know that as soon as I
do this Knight to e4 will probably hit
you know so we have a little back and
forth if they play this really quick
they're probably content with the draw I
don't want that okay maybe this is a
different moment now
okay well let's go for something defend
here dark-squared bishop exchange
yeah but I could still do this it is a
little scary but these nights offset I
have this square covered from eight
still want this in so 9f for I don't
think there should be any great
sacrifices here this Bishop is not
flying let's get the dark square Bishop
solve
maybe my king is good here
tough
I think I will be taking the night out
mmm this may be something that they can
capitalize on okay definitely take me
tonight keep the Queens on still I may
just do this this is unprotected so
Queen here I don't know if I could do
this maybe if I could establish a night
here that's something yeah if I could do
this
get the Queen's off maybe right now is a
moment for that but no I'm still gonna
hold my ground
I want to improve a little bit further
maybe have my night here before I go in
for some Queen exchange
they have isolated ponds and a pond that
is I'm chalking up as potentially
isolated
yeah he's he's cut off he's disjointed
here
so some slow improving moves for me
would be clean here I missing anything
for 13 seconds
and I can't go too far h2 there's a
check but gladly step up to e7 the Queen
goes too far and I have this check no
fancy tactics here have this square
covered offer of a queen exchange no
let's go here now I'm pointing at B -
slowly slowly getting somewhere can
maybe even post up on f4 and look for
this that could really really sting
okay maybe maybe even g5 plays a role
let's do this my queen is excellent
eight seconds my clock is not excellent
a timely g5 okay let's do that
oh my goodness five seconds I got to go
faster
maybe closer to getting that Queen
exchange
clean here like they can't move so
easily
okay they still go for a queen h2 stuff
Queen here Queen check maybe a knight on
e5 oh they dropped upon and another one
- I guess the bishop will have to block
otherwise he falls
yeah now I think I'm okay with this
get right into that c5 square
well I could force the issue very soon
maybe should have captured the night
first honor if this was even there right
now why why would I do it like this so
sooner my opponents offering a draw that
was that was not a good idea this is
this is something vulnerable I'll be
able to centralize my king well this
prong could get all the way to f4 that's
nice I have the better king position I'm
up upon I should still be able to
convert this
you know I gotta go with this I think
let's get a passed pawn
let's get my night here maybe they're
offering a draw I don't want a draw
defending this pawn I get my King here
very soon let's give a check get here
next Bishop has to try to go here now it
is certainly a win King and pawn ending
is winning
okay yeah they're trying to I don't know
a little back and forth they were trying
to burn time or whatever but do you have
that increment whoo that was a game of
inches
I got a say my opponent wasn't giving
much I can't quite recall what position
it was exactly when I referenced H 5 H 4
but that turned to that turned out to be
the key idea
okay let's go through it without looking
at the analysis for starters
Widow are to start but we kind of
transpose into some exchange French okay
yeah I was able to voice a lot I think
this is the right decision I guess this
will be one to look back on whether to
take with the bishop or the pawn
this was my fear
B for now what if I take this rook is
very happy this pawn not so happy and if
I do not take what do I do
I got defend upon but now this is always
an option and these this is a very clear
plan these guys are getting too too
close so I believe that this is a really
really important decision on how to
recapture here beep on I have to make
sure I keep this majority at bay it is a
three versus two after all so there was
a little battle here for the be four
square I was able to hold it up with a
four and then we had a lot of poking
around in wing h5 is now the one moment
where I believe I could get away with
that because on this I get the B to pawn
now the Queen is no longer on c2 that's
what kept me from doing that move in
what position maybe right here because
not getting a b2 right now but you know
the position of the queen is now just a
hair different being on d3
and now the H pawn is the one that
really breaks down white structure you
know I want to keep Queens on ideally I
have the safer King and once we got the
dark square Bishop exchange I had an
easier time improving ya notice notice
something here while we were playing
with about bishops and either of us were
able to approach with our Kings because
we weren't there's with both bishops
still on board it's not it's not clear
where there is a reliable home for your
king so as soon as the dark square
bishop s-- were off now he's getting his
king involved White's getting the King
involved I'm getting my king involved
dark squares opposite the bishops and
yeah it's easy to go wrong I guess right
around this point for white I have a
really strong Queen Vetter night if you
do piece comparison better posts for the
Queen the night
maybe slightly better king position
structure is better mmm and the bishop
is pretty passive so these are all these
all these positional features all add up
of course didn't have to drop upon here
but I think they're still struggling
some for sure and they kind of have to
wait I don't know if f6 was best maybe
giving a check here and playing this but
I have to be a little bit careful of g5
maybe g5 wasn't necessary I could maybe
do without g5 but I had some and I had
some idea in mind with diverting the
pawn away from e4 and sets up some
timely Forks you know and this ending
here wonder if I could just keep Queens
on no I think this is fine but I
shouldn't be capturing this Knight
I don't think maybe I have to maybe no
no no I shouldn't be capturing Queens
how about this and then oh I don't know
mmm it's tricky
alright because I thought even being up
upon in this ending that there may have
been some drawing idea where let's see
right around this point instead that
Bishop move like Bishop here now I have
to do this and then King here and my
knight I don't know like I could do this
kind of stuff and still get the passed
pawn but I can't move my knight
I feel like white a computer would be
able to hold this as white somehow
you know the night is a bit clumsy just
forgetting that this would be different
if I had a pond that needed support like
I don't know if it was closer to the
center and my king could be the one that
guards the pond that the bishop was
putting pressure on but he's so far away
and my night is awkward having to defend
it from b6 mmm so I wonder if I could
have done something better right around
here I'm not not seeing it just yet but
I guess we could just throw on the
engine and see what some of the
suggestions are yeah it's even yeah it
doesn't like the Queen takes e3 but
let's just get an analysis Oh
oh my goodness White had something look
at this oh man what did I miss
oh they had a fortnight Tate Knight to
f5 oh my goodness that would have stung
so bad
when I played Queen here Knight f5 game
over
oh man oh wow
ouch that would have hurt really really
bad hmm we were both a bit under
pressure there the clock ah man I was
yeah I was blind to that clearly so
that's a loser night to have five
so let's suggest maybe King 2d6
yeah I was you know I wasn't even
looking at anything like that I didn't I
didn't see any offensive type moves
white hat but who definitely dodged a
bullet there
ouch okay well let's just skim through
here with the engine aside from that
there is a progression there tipping in
blacks favor and that key move I want to
have a look at it's roughly equal for
some time
let's see
yeah
can also question the oh I went I went
past it so right here Bishop takes e5
this was my concern
before now what does it want to do
yeah I don't like this at all King to f8
um and on b5 hmm I don't know I just I
see these these pawns just creeping
closer and it's concerns me it's still
reading level but look at how these guys
just are set into motion here takes
Bishop takes can white not continue push
this is this is something to be avoided
okay maybe the computer is holding this
but this is extra scary you know like
already I have to be very careful about
the number of pieces that are exchanged
if they're all exchanged then this is a
one King and pawn ending for white these
guys are just too far advanced and at
any point they could dart towards the
promotion rank I'm not stopping them
well if I'm too far away they just take
off so I don't know I think I made the
right decision even though the
evaluation is reading you know there
isn't a fluctuation with it I think I it
is the right idea to not even allow
these guys to be set into motion and
once the if h5 was the right move when I
played it I only got a Queen exchange
but
97 was was popping up h5 now likes h5
make up your mind hmm
well I guess this is one of the moves I
did go forward with it yeah now now it's
something so I guess they had to go with
h3 because what did he end up doing he
got to h3 and it broke down the whole
structure so this is an instructive
point you have to play h3 here he is
still a great thorn but he isn't putting
a dent he isn't making the Jeep on
flinch he isn't saddling light with two
isolated ponds near the white king so h3
was called for but because of f3 I'm
able to go forward with this plan and
yeah now these guys are split mm-hmm
and a bullet was dodged is this the
other another good idea night here night
tui
yeah I guess it's okay with this idea
dark square Bishop Soph and then slowly
get the Kings involved and next time
don't fall for or even put yourself in a
position to get forked like that oh that
would have been so bad so King to d6 it
wants to go for you know pretty decisive
advantage there all these positional
factors add up but you could throw them
all out the window if you're playing
Queen to d4 I would have threw in the
towel right there okay well dodged one
bullet but aside from that I was pleased
with how I played this one out of the
French defense okay well as usual if you
have any feedback to this video feel
free to leave it in the comment section
below and as always I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care
by